Myth: Lemmings commit mass suicide.
So when did this myth get started?
Well, nobody knows exactly, but it was a 1958
documentary by Disney, which won an Academy
Award, by the way, that appears to have popularized
the myth.
In the wildlife documentary White Wilderness,
a few dozen lemmings were imported to Alberta,
Canada so that they could be filmed in their
“natural” habitat.
The film makers used close up shots to make
it seem like there were thousands of lemmings
migrating.
They had the lemmings on a snow covered lazy-Susan
style turntable and just filmed them as they
ran.
They also filmed them crossing a little stream.
Once they got all the shots they needed, they
then used the turntable to launch the lemmings
over a cliff into a river and filmed this
in the same way, making it seem like a mass
lemming suicide was taking place.
The next scene was of the dead lemmings floating
in the water.
The theory behind why they would commit this
mass suicide, as explained by narrator Winston
Hibler, is that they get worked up from the
frenzy of running with all the other thousands
of lemmings: “A kind of compulsion seizes
each tiny rodent and, carried along by an
unreasoning hysteria, each falls into step
for a march that will take them to a strange
destiny.”
He then proceeds to explain how they are approaching
the sea, which is actually just a river because
Alberta is landlocked; at which point, driven
by their hysteria, they cast themselves into
the sea.
None of this is true.
Lemmings actually prefer to be on their own,
only getting together to mate when food is
plentiful.
However, lemmings can literally go from massively
overpopulated in a certain area to near extinction
within a couple year period and then back
to massively overpopulated very quickly.
This actually happens in a semi-regular cycle
of about three to four years and, to date,
nobody knows exactly why.
The standard theory is that it simply has
to do with available food sources, predators,
and the harsh environment they live in (often
in extremely cold regions like Northern Alaska
and the like).
When the lemmings are in the upswing where
they are massively overpopulated, they tend
to go into a phase where they like to spread
out and disperse to new areas where food is
more plentiful and there is less competition
for that food.
When this dispersal to new areas happens,
they can sometimes appear to be traveling
in large groups.
But this is just because there are so many
of them, they aren’t actually traveling
together.
It’s a dispersal, not a migration.
When they are dispersing, they often do find
themselves in the water.
But here’s the thing.
Lemmings can swim.
And actually, given their size (about the
size of a mouse or hamster), they can swim
a pretty incredible distance (about 200 meters
or around 600 feet).
So in their quest to spread out, they will
occasionally choose to try to swim to another
place and many die in the attempt, only to
be washed up on shore later.
There are even documented cases of this where
massive numbers of them will drown in the
attempt to reach a shore that was too far
for them or if the water was too choppy, they
can die from that, even though the distance
wasn’t too far.
When enough of them try to disperse to whatever
far shore and fail, the dead lemmings will
pile up on the beach, perhaps giving the impression
they committed mass suicide in some sort of
frenzied group migration.
In addition, shortly after this population
explosion happens, their population begins
a very steep decline to near extinction, probably
giving credence to the fact that all the lemmings
banded together and migrated to their deaths
in the water.
In any event, it is often cited that it was
this Disney documentary that started the myth,
but that is not the case either.
There is a reference to huge numbers of lemmings
jumping off cliffs from a 1954 American Mercury
article, which is a full four years before
Disney’s documentary came out.
On top of that, there was a 1955 comic by
Carl Barks titled “The Lemming with the
Locket” that portrayed the same type of
thing.
All of that aside, the people working on the
documentary took their job very seriously,
so they wouldn’t have just made something
up like that; they clearly thought it was
true.
It was very common back then, and to a much
lesser extent today, for people making nature
documentaries to simulate or force actual
wildlife events like this by making the animals
do what was needed of them for the shot.
This was just a case of the film makers thinking
this was true about lemmings, so making it
happen so they could film it.
As to how far back the myth goes before the
Disney documentary, nobody knows, but it is
pretty clear that at least it was around before
this documentary began filming.